-Hey guys.
I'm here with Michelle Obama.
And we're about to
surprise some people.
They're going
on a tour of 30 Rock.
They think they're going on
a tour of 30 Rock.
And they're going to stop
on the wrong floor --
this floor.
And that's where we step in.
Ready to do this?
-Yeah.
Cat.
-And we're leading.
-This is great, Jimmy.
-Oh, my God.
-This is a great book.
This is a great book.
You got to read this book.
Is your book good?
-I think this is
really intelligent.
-And I can...
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Screams ]
-Ever seen a magic trick?
Check this out. Watch this.
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
Hi, guys.
-Hey!
-♪ Jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride in
a one-horse open sleigh ♪
Happy holidays.
-Hi.
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-Are you okay?
Hey, guys.
You mind if I go down?
I just want to --
Actually, you know what?
We'll take the next one.
-Wait, wait, wait.
I thought we were --
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Hey. How you doing?
Happy holidays.
Wait.
I'm like, "Forgive me."
-Uh...oh, well.
-Perfect.
-Okay.
Well, why don't we
just take the stairs?
-No, I thought that you were --
We were both gonna --
-Why are you such a wimp?
-I can walk back up if you want.
-Whatever.
[ Cheers and applause ]